après trois jours et trois nuits le
moral est toujours là ça vaut mieux
peut-être
la guerre il y a combien de centimètres
d'eau à votre avis ce matin
[Musique]
les pompiers j'écoute 12 rue villa des
fleurs c'est à Montrouge
117 rue de la Convention mais écoutez
madame
il faut patienter un peu hein mais oui
mais vous n'êtes pas la seule madame
au combien quelle adresse Monsieur alors
on arrive aussi madame
4h du matin pour Brancion sous le tunnel
du boulevard périphérique
les sapeurs-pompiers interviennent pour
sauvetage de 5 automobilistes d'un
cerclé par les eaux dont trois
chauffeurs de poids lourds
[Musique]
tu peux monter sur le dossier
il y avait pas tellement tellement doux
il y avait environ peut-être 40 cm alors
j'ai voulu essayer de passer et puis
alors évidemment le moteur je me suis
retrouvé
mais alors en Espagne de 5 minutes c'est
monté peut-être à mettre un mètre 50
quoi
4h45 dans le 15e arrondissement un
garage fait appel à la brigade pour
inondation dans un parking sous-sol mais
si Paris a connu de violences orages la
région parisienne a vu tout d'abord son
trafic ferroviaire gravement perturbé
dans le Val-d'Oise
[Musique]
Lucien à la garde de monstre
au 17 800 à 10 pour l'instant monsieur
nous sommes sur quelle voie
et là interrompu depuis quelle heure
je me suis retrouvé
5h30
depuis 14h30
et il est maintenant 6h05 est-ce que
vous avez un espoir pour la journée
ça passe
toujours dans le Val-d'Oise les
habitants des localités des envies les
coins ont vécu une nouvelle fois une
nuit de cauchemars alors qu'hier au
cours de la journée un espoir était né
après 3 jours et 3 nuits le moral est
toujours là ça vaut mieux peut-être
la guerre il y a combien de centimètres
d'eau à votre avis ce matin
comme un grenier qu'est-ce qu'on peut
dire ce matin elle a l'alerte a été
déclenché à 3h30 à peu près on a fait
évacuer la cité d'urgence avant que
l'Aumont actuellement on procède à
l'évacuation terminée
et ce qui intéresse surtout les
sinistrés c'est l'hébergement d'une part
pour ceux qui sont évacués et d'autre
part la nourriture
dit il faut reconnaître que la
population
malgré le malheur qu'il est frappe fait
preuve de beaucoup de courage et
essaie de garder le sourire je sais que
c'était pas très facile mais enfin ça
fait ça fait plaisir au sauveteur
d'ailleurs de voir que
malgré leur souci ils essaient de rendre
la tâche le plus facile possible si des
gens
arrive à garder le moral il y en a
d'autres qui bien évidemment sont dans
un désarroi total pourquoi vous en
doutez ils ont tout perdu
madame
vous êtes sinistrés à 100%
et votre maison se trouve à quel endroit
[Musique]
et c'est la troisième nuit alors la
deuxième nuit alors
cette maison datée
mais j'étais heureuse j'étais contente
[Musique]